the Joe Rogan experience what do you see
what's happening with Justin Trudeau the
Prime Minister of Canada yeah they found
brown face so he was dressed in a happy
- how did they find all three of them
the same [ __ ] day well some I was
searching for some [ __ ] you know mid but
it's he was in a costume in 1981 and
we're upset we really anything they make
people were at real tweets were saying
that he should be horrified by this
racism like is he is he just in a
costume because it seems like he's just
in a costume pretending these an Arabian
guy is that really racist is called
Arabian Nights yeah was it I mean maybe
ours insensitive now today but in 1981
guess what no one cares did a 1981 that
one of the biggest films I think are not
biggest a big film was uh so Silver
Streak
my brother will older brothers obsessed
with trains fact he works for Amtrak now
but in that movie there's a scene where
Gene Wilder has to put on blackface yes
and um you know that of course was never
gone now and I could see I somebody
fight offended but at the time when I
saw that for the first time when I was
six or seven like you know that was a
different time do you member see Thomas
how soul man remember that movie yeah
those like in the 90s played I who
pretended to be black to go to a certain
school do you remember that I remember
2001 oh not at 1981 just declare which
one did Justin Trudeau's stuff here's
like 10 1981 yeah oh it happened in 2000
yeah yeah 18 years ago oh why does
anyone where they here was anyone
maybe I just repeated dumb numbers but
what I don't know man I I've never worn
a black face and I sure as [ __ ] would
remember it if I'd ever put it on that's
why I don't think I don't remember that
pulling that movie soul man what thomas
Howell who was it that said they
couldn't remember wearing it someone
that got in trouble a lot of person
before oh yeah who was that that was
like a senator it's somebody from
Kentucky I don't know I don't know I
could tell you everything I was for
Halloween it I was Orville Redenbacher
[Music]
[ __ ] this is see thomas Howell and
that's when he's he's the white guy and
I forget what exactly it was tanning
pills to get into school is that what it
was he took tanning pills oh my goodness
to get into a school he took tantric
pills I've been the Harvard of some
college or something like that oh okay
so and then screwed ahead to when he
turns into a black fellow and also did
you see my Garrity's did you see what he
was talking into what was he talking
into a noose oh Jesus
so he's gonna kill himself because he
took too many tanning pills practice he
couldn't get in at college oh right well
I took the tanning pills getting go but
go to the picture of Hill who's looking
in the mirror but imagine if you decided
that maybe we should imagine if you're
gonna make this movie today oh my god
they would hang you is that Julie Liu
this was like a harmless movie in 1990
whatever it was when this movie came out
this was an absolutely harmless movie
that nobody protested about nobody cared
it was really obvious what was going it
was not a not a great movie but nobody
cared imagine if you put that movie out
today dude oh my god and you know I was
thinking about the other day I was
thinking about how [ __ ] insane Doogie
Howser is I was like I was [ __ ] sick
and a twelve-year-old was like seriously
that's right he was a doctor he's a
12-year old doctor every get the [ __ ]
out of here [ __ ] yeah like
seriously but doctor was he dude I don't
know but then I realized something I was
like that it like this not only was he a
doctor but like he every night after the
day he was he would sit down at his
computer as journal and to his journal
which is I know for a fact that like I
don't know for a fact that I'm pretty
sure that the whole basis of sex in the
cities is based on that do you
Doogie Howser I think they I think that
they are connected you know how like
they say that Family Matters is a
spin-off of South Park perfectly Simpson
perfect strangers perfect strangers
the elevator door manner why was it
isn't strange rattling off different
cartoons perfect perfect strangers is
supposed to take place in the same
universe as Family Matters but I do
think sex in the city takes place in the
same universe as Doogie Howser and maybe
if you think of oh what's that guy that
she's always trying to date that just
had mr. big
maybe mr. BIG's Doogie Howser as an
adult oh yeah
never know never know I never connected
those two I don't think I ever watched
an episode of Doogie Howser and I've
only reluctantly watched an episode
Preston city clown was on it a couple
years younger than you so we were
subjected to that [ __ ] but now kids
don't even watch that there's three
channels when we were kids yeah kids
barely watch TV anymore what is it he
was a second-year resident surgeon even
cutting into people for a year already
oh my god
[Applause]